Tonya Harding makes a surprise
appearance at the I Tonya premiere
[Music]
the former Olympian was living her best
life on Tuesday Tonya rocking a little
black dress as she worked it for the
cameras with her husband Joseph Jen's
price by her side the film chronicles
Tanya's rise and fall in the world of
competitive figure skating I mean come
on what kind of friggin person bashes in
their friend's knee who'd do that to a
friend the 47 year olds also posed with
Margot Robbie who not only plays Tonya
on screen but also produced the flick
with her husband Tom ackerly and you and
Tom really have created a triumph with
this film what is the key to successful
working relationships a lot of couples
can't even share a closet yeah the whole
team's just think works incredibly well
together Tom and I work well together
Tonya was the only woman in the US who
did the triple axel and that's an
accomplished was number one that's an
accomplishment no one can ever take away
from her what is one accomplishment that
you feel at this point you've achieved
that you're really proud of it so many
things have happened that I that I still
pinch myself that I can't believe it's
quite true honestly being here tonight I
mean it's the Egyptian theater and the
middle of Hollywood it's it's a quite
surreal
[Music]